John Legend and Chrissy Teigen getting a
jump on the holidays with their first
Christmas special it's a house party at
the legend
so here's John and Christine Christmas
speed round favorite dish that Chrissy
makes for the holidays I love the new
beef wellington we started during that
last year and it was amazing and it's
gonna be a Christmas tradition friends
and family includes Stevie Wonder Kim
Kardashian Kris Jenner
aquafina and air cub they are also a
part of a legendary Christmas with John
and Chrissy favorite celebrity guests -
Carol with on the show Meghan Trainor
was a lot of fun and she brought extra
sweaters another guest Darren Criss both
he and Jon won Emmys this year but in
one category Darren actually beat John
percent chance that you and Darren
brought your Emmys to go Christmas
querida scuzz that he beat me for an
Emmy me yeah but he should have been me
I know it's all good I said I was gonna
call you rush the stage if you can win
favorite Christmas memory growing up oh
my gosh probably my putting out the
cookies for Santa and then catching my
dad in the act of eating them if that is
on Lunas Christmas list this year oh
gosh
she doesn't even know what she wants
what I want to Christie John I hope
you're sending my present by the way
John also released his first Christmas
album the legendary Christmas and he's
out on tour playing Toronto tomorrow
[Music]